Se nos dice que: "Sara concluyó que:
'Los cuadriláteros -estos dos de aquí-
tienen cuatro pares de ángulos congruentes
correspondientes'", podemos ver esto justo aquí,
y basándose en eso ella concluye que "las figuras
son semejantes. ¿Qué error -si hubo alguno-
cometió Sara en su conclusión?" Pausa este video
e intenta resolverlo por tu cuenta. Muy bien,
recordemos una definición de semejanza
que usamos a menudo en clase de geometría,
y es que dos figuras son semejantes si
se pueden mapear mediante una serie de
transformaciones rígidas y homotecias, una figura
sobre la otra. Ahora, al ver estas dos figuras,
podríamos intentar hacer algo, podríamos decir que
vamos a trasladarla para que K se mapee en H, y si
hiciéramos eso parece que L se mapearía en G; pero
estos lados KN y LM parecen bastante más largos,
y si intentamos hacer la homotecia para que la
longitud de KN sea igual a la longitud de HI,
entonces las longitudes de KL y GH serían
diferentes. Así que no parece que se pueda hacer
esto, por eso es extraño que Sara concluya que son
semejantes; entonces, encontremos el error. Bueno,
ya descartamos C, que dice que es una conclusión
correcta, porque no creo que sean semejantes.
Veamos, ¿está el error en una transformación
rígida -una traslación- mapearía HG en KL,
por lo que los cuadriláteros son congruentes,
no semejantes? O la opción A dice algo aún
más fuerte, porque cualquier cosa que sea
congruente va a ser semejante. En realidad
no puedes tener algo congruente y no semejante,
y por eso la opción A no tiene ningún sentido,
así que nuestro razonamiento deductivo nos dice
que, probablemente B, sea la opción correcta,
pero vamos a leerlo: "Es imposible mapear el
cuadrilátero GHIJ en el cuadrilátero LKNM usando
sólo transformaciones rígidas y homotecias,
por lo que las figuras no son semejantes". Sí,
es cierto, podríamos intentar, podríamos mapear
HG en KL, pero luego el segmento IJ se vería así,
IJ estaría justo aquí, y luego si tratamos
de escalarlo para que la longitud de HI y
GJ coincidan con KN o LM, entonces también
haremos que HG sea más grande, por lo que
nunca podremos mapearlos entre sí, incluso si
usamos homotecias. Entonces me gusta la opción B.